So anyway, in conclusion, the best thing Kevin
Feige did was making Cowboys and Aliens starring
Jon Favreau. I'm here with Tom and Nina to ask the
question, what are the best and worst decisions
Kevin Feige has made with the MCU.
Nina, why don't you start us off?
Thanks, Brian. So worst is tough because as
you said, most of these movies are pretty good.
They've performed really spectacularly well at
the box office. They're critically ... For the
most part, I mean, Avengers: Infinity War and
Endgame did very well with critics. Many of the
smaller ones have as well. So I think worst is,
is tough. And it's very relative when it comes
to Kevin Feige running the MCU, because
he's done a really good job as somebody-
It's hard to find the bad
stuff amongst so much good.
But something that concerns me. And I'll
admit that when I was doing research for this,
I stumbled across a piece written
by Emily VanDerWerff, who is,
I believe the critic at large at
Fox. And she made a good point,
where she was like, "The MCU is the
most television-esque thing in film
right now," in that sure, you can watch the
movies by themselves, but they're really episodic.
And if you watch Captain America: Winter Soldier
without having seen the first Captain America,
you don't really understand why he is really
anxious about government oversight. You don't
really get like the smaller kind of character
beats if you don't watch the entire thing.
And I think that, that level of interconnectedness
can get really tricky because then you start,
especially with so many movies, I think that
a casual viewer might start to feel alienated
by the entire thing. And I think that, that
concerns me going forward. I mean, an example is
during quarantine, I live near my parents, we
watched a lot of movies together. I couldn't
have shown them Infinity War Endgame. They would
have been like, "Who were any of these people?"
Because they don't watch Marvel movies. But
I can show them Black Panther because it is
a complete standalone. And you can understand
that movie really, really well without ... Even
though Klaue is in other movies, you
don't need to know who he is beforehand.
You don't really need to
know who he is during either.
No. And even if you haven't seen Captain America:
Civil war and the introduction of T'Challah,
you don't really need that either. You
just know when this movie opens that his
father has passed away. So I think the
interconnectedness is a great strength,
but it could be a weakness, in
that I think it could alienate
more casual viewers who don't want to watch
20-plus movies to understand what's going on.
I agree with you in theory, I think
that obviously it's daunting, right?
Right.
If I really, really like Captain America:
Winter Soldier, and I want to say to someone,
"Hey, let's watch Winter Soldier,"
and be like, "Well, do I need to
see any other movies to understand it?" And
I'll be like, "Yes." But at the same time,
I guess that weakness is also the whole
franchise's strength because it's driven-
Totally.
... everybody to see every one of
these movies because they watch.
That's true. But as you know, phase four
continues, and there's so much more,
and there's TV shows. I mean, I don't know-
So much.
... what casual viewer could have wandered into
Falcon and the Winter Soldier having seen every
other movie. Even as someone who's seen all
the Marvel movies, I still sometimes was like,
"Wait, who, what?" I mean, even I got a little
bogged down. And then quickly, I think the best
thing, and I think we talked about this our
chat at some point. And it was something that
I brought up. I think something he's done
that's really smart is bringing in smaller
directors who ... He brings in a lot of television
directors. So the Russos worked on shows like
Happy Endings and Arrested Development.
And then he was like, "Do you want to
helm some of the biggest installments in
this entire thing?" And they crushed it.
I mean, the Russos did a great job with Civil
War and Infinity War and Endgame. So I think
that way before Chloe Zhao was out there winning
Academy awards, he tapped her to direct Eternals.
So I think he has a really good sense of who
should helm which story and whose sensibility
is right. And I think he has done a good job
in picking people who are less well-known,
but perfect for the job, instead of just being
like, "Hey, Steven Spielberg," or whatever,
"do you want to do at MCU movie." Not that,
that would be bad, but it's just nice to see
him giving a chance to people who you don't
know as well and making them household names.
If I could pick up the baton and run with
it before we throw to Tom, that is also
very similar to my best and worst decision. So
for me, one of the worst decisions he's made,
and I guess I'm speculating here about what
actually was his decision, but as the boss,
I;m going to assume that most of the felt
to him, was when Edgar Wright left Ant-Man.
Edgar Wright is an amazing director.
Every film has done is very good, to
extremely good. Even if one of the movies
that he did is not your favorite or has some
issues here and there, overall it's
still better than most other movies.
He also has carved out such a distinctive style
in the vein of Wes Anderson, where it's like, if
you see five minutes of an Edgar Wright movie, you
know that it's an Edgar Wright movie immediately.
While I really liked Ant-Man and Ant-Man
Two, I really like Peyton Reed's work,
the director of those movies, I think he's
cool, I think he's great, I still really
would have loved to have seen Edgar Wright.
And I think that would have been amazing.
Was that a creative differences
problem? Is that what happened?
Yeah, something like that. It's basically just
kind of ... It's never really been made clear
what happened and why it happened that way. But
yeah, creative differences is generally what's-
So you're saying that letting Edgar Wright
slip through his fingers was Kevin Feige's
biggest mistake?
I feel like doing things to keep him happy
would have ultimately made for a really
memorable and exciting movie, right?
Yeah.
Like James Gunn, Guardians of the Galaxy. That's
a James Gunn movie. And then the next one I was
going to say, that one of the best decisions
he made was after that he got Taika Waititi
to revitalize Thor and get Thor: Ragnarok on
the track that it was on. And that's one now, it
went from a franchise I didn't really care about,
the Thor franchise, to of my absolute, not only
just favorite MCU movies, but Thor: Ragnarok is
one of my favorite movies in recent memory, where-
And by getting Taika on board, he got Natalie
Portman back into the MCU. I don't think she
would have signed on had she'd not seen a totally
different vision for this character and the story.
Yeah. There's new and interesting things
happening. So many of these MCU movies,
as much as I enjoy them for what they
are, like the bare bones, like, hey,
they're super heroes fighting, I like them when
they're interesting and different and weird.
And the way that you brought up the
Guardians is a James Gunn movie, Thor:
Ragnarok is a Taika Waititi movie.
I mean, if you're familiar with
Jojo Rabbit, or What We Do In the Shadows,
it has that same, very dry sensibility.
He's got a great sense of humor. So they let him
just play around and figure out a new direction.
So yeah, that's my best and worst, where the worst
was early on Edgar Wright getting away, when that
could have been the start of really cool stuff.
But best, learning from that mistake and then
starting to right the ship with people like James
Gunn and Taika Waititi. So those are my picks.
Tom, what about you? What are your best and worst
decisions that Kevin Feige has made with the MCU?
Totally agree. I think it's kind of
remarkable, especially with something as big as
the MCU became, this guy overall,
and I wasn't there, I don't know,
but from what I understand really trusted
the creative people that he was hiring. He
knew that these people were good at something for
a reason. And so, even going back to Iron Man,
you read about John Favreau going up to bat to
bring Robert Downey Jr. on board, when the studio
maybe wanted somebody a little bit less could
be found in the ditch at any moment. You know?
Right. Right.
from public perception.
I found that screenshot from a very popular
entertainment site from 2009 that said,
"Marvel takes a chance on two no names for Thor."
And it was Tom Hiddleston and Chris Hemsworth.
And now they're like, oh, okay. Just two of
the biggest movie stars on the planet, fine.
That's another thing. He found these pretty great
directors, people who fit with what he was trying
to make, especially back at the beginning. I
mean, I know that the first Thor movie is nobody's
favorite anything, but getting a Shakespearian
director to try and handle these over-the-top-
It's a good point, yeah.
...and then going onto Captain
America, first Captain America,
which was directed by Chris Columbus.
No.
No. It was who did The Rocketeer. Right?
It was the guy who did The Rocketeer. I want
to say his name starts with Joe. Excuse my-
Joe.
I'm going to type-
It wasn't Joe
... on my lap
It's Joe Johnston.
That's it, Joe Johnston. I didn't
have to type on my keyboard, which -
I have a very quiet keyboard. I got it.
Good job. Thank you.
Well, then I'm going to go to you for facts, Nina.
Tom, it's really interesting that you bring
up John Favreau too, because has there been
anyone more prolific in terms of directing and
creating stuff that we all like than John Favreau?
He kicked off the MCU with Iron
Man. He did The Mandalorian. He's-
He made Zathura.
Well, sure.
Is that-
not all-
Is that a point in his favor? I never saw.
I haven't seen it either.
I just assumed that we were
all on team Zathura. I guess-
I can be.
... it doesn't matter.
I'm very flexible about a movie I haven't seen.
A better question is are you
team cowboys, or team aliens?
Ooh.
Because he also directed Cowboys and Aliens.
How can you ask me to choose-
Sure did.
... between my children in such a way?
I love them both in different ways.
I actually heard that movie's-
coming to life.
I heard that movie's really good,
but I still haven't gotten around-
I heard it's a really fun action
movie. Not everything needs to be an
Oscar-winner. It can just be fun and kind of dumb.
I'd watch it tomorrow if I knew any way
to watch it without paying money for it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's really brave of you to say, Brian.
I know. I'm taking a stand here
and now. Cowboys and Aliens,
I want to watch you, but I
don't want to pay for you.
Just not for money.
Well, not for more money than-
I want to watch you-
I've already paid.
Yeah. You want to watch the
movie, but not that badly.
I don't want to pay $3. Actually. I would pay $3.
You wouldn't buy it for $15, but
I think you'd rent it for three.
I'm really enjoying the emotional
journey that you're going on.
I'm just trying to find my floor
and ceiling for my desire to watch
Cowboys and Aliens starring Daniel
Craig and Harrison Ford, I presume-
episode of Shrek that-
... as a cowboy and as an alien.
I'm sorry. I didn't realize that's who
starred in that movie. Now I have to watch it.
Now you have to watch it, right?
I have to.
I can't resist.
Which one is a cowboy and which one is an alien?
If Harrison Ford is not a cowboy,
I'm not watching the movie.
What if he's a cowboy alien? What if they've
come together at the end? And they're like,
"Actually, the aliens were
cowboys the whole time."
Actually, the Cowboys and aliens were
the friends we made along the way.
That's right, the friends we made along the way.
Pitching the plot of a movie that came
out 10 years ago, pretty hard right now.
And then at the end, they're like, "This
is so money." And then it cuts to black.
Sp money, you don't even know.
Jon Favreau, a film by Jon
Favreau. And then the end-
Jon Favreau's joint.
Then the end is just ... It's
just outtakes from him on Friends.
Oh, God.
Outstanding. Outstanding
I'd pay $4 to rent this movie.
Well, I'm glad we made up the plot
to a movie none of us have seen.
Yeah. I don't know what we did
here today, but I'm glad we did it.
Anyway, in conclusion, the best thing Kevin Feige
did was making Cowboys and
Aliens, starting Jon Favreau.
The centerpiece, the crown jewel of the MCU.
Yeah. I love that.
the line from Swingers and
the outtakes from Friends.
Yeah. It's a movie we all want to watch.
Marvel paid a billion dollars.
If Marvel put out Cowboys and Aliens
it would make a billion dollars.
Yeah, it probably would.
It is based on a comic book. The story
behind that, I don't know all the details,
but I'm pretty sure that the person who made that
comic book specifically did it so
that he could get a movie option.
I mean, also I think Marvel could put out an
Andy Warhol style video of Robert Downey Jr.
Sleeping for eight hours and it would make
a billion dollars. I'd probably go watch it.
It would be-
The trailer would be great anyway.
Yeah. I'd watch it.
What does that guy get up to when
he's asleep, what does he do?
Probably not much, but I got to know.
Thanks for joining us. Please hit like and
subscribe, so you don't miss a single new episode.